tell you what's not a good solution
is having police who could be
investigating unsolved rapes and murders
get distracted with paperwork
to give citations to people who don't
have anywhere to use the toilet in
private
oh so there's human feces on the
sidewalk but it's your fault for not
building more public totes how about no
crapping on the sidewalk how's that
sound and that is the message actually
that san francisco voters sent yesterday
and the reason they were able to
trace his back to a man called david
sachs he's one of the people who funded
this recall election he's the co-founder
of craft ventures where he's a partner
he's also the former ceo of paypal and
we're happy to have him join us tonight
to celebrate the triumph of democracy in
his city san francisco congratulations
it were you surprised by the margins
here they seemed huge given the city
yeah thank you tucker it's great to be
here um yeah you know boudin tried to
portray this recall as a republican
recall he called it trumpist
but you know only seven percent of san
francisco uh voters are registered
republicans it's a 90 democrat city and
so the 60
majority shows you that mainstream
democrats and moderates throughout the
city rejected this sort of radical
progressive agenda and so i think what
you're seeing now is some boundary lines
are being drawn inside the democratic
party where average democratic voters
are starting to push back against the
activists and the woke billionaires the
donor class and the unions and the
special interests who are trying to push
a agenda that's out of step even with
the liberal citizens of san francisco
well exactly and the idea this is some
sort of trumpist effort you merely
whatever your politics are stepped in
and gave voters the opportunity to weigh
in because it is an emergency what's
happening in your city i think it's fair
to say so you just
allowed democracy to take place how
could anyone complain about that
right and you know it wasn't just me
there are many other
organizations and individuals who
contributed who uh you know are
registered democrats and so it was very
much a broad-based effort of uh people
in san francisco rejecting this sort of
radical decarcerationist agenda where
chase abu deen had this idea that he
could make san francisco safer by
emptying out the jails and and releasing
or decreasing the prison population as
much as possible they call it
decarcerationism uh obviously it
backfired massively and we're all living
with the results of that now in san
francisco and you know just san
franciscans from all walks of life have
basically rejected that agenda but you
know like i said the
sort of activist wing in the democratic
party is still deeply invested in it and
it's going to take a lot more than one
election to get them to reject it and uh
so you know this sort of playbook here
is gonna have to be replicated across
the country
really so you honestly don't and you
follow this closely
if they lose in san francisco that's not
a clear enough message for them
well you know i think you've got the
these sort of decarceral prosecutors
who've been elected in la and chicago
new york city austin uh philadelphia uh
you know they're backed by very deep
pocketed sort of work billionaires soros
reed hastings and so forth they're not
going to change their minds just based
on one election so they may change their
messaging but i don't think they're
going to change their minds it's going
to take you know effort
in many of these cities
to try and see to try and make a change
yeah it's going to take democracy amen
david sachs congratulations you really
have helped make that city better we
appreciate it thank you
thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight